so last thursday night joe biden gave
just a good
solid convention speech at the end of
the dnc and he's seen his favorability
go up by five points
now this is exactly why republicans said
on mond
last monday biden might get eight to ten
points out of the dnc
why did they do that because never does
any presidential candidate get eight to
ten points out of the dnc
the reason republicans said it was so
that when biden gets
five or three or four they can say oh
he's really underperforming we expected
biden to get eight to ten points he only
got three four or five now
what's more interesting to me is
typically conventions will boost polling
and favorability by three to four
joe biden is actually exceeding that in
the latest abc news ipsos poll
which says biden's favorability went
from 40 to 45
in one week now that's still very low
in other words 40 is bad 45
is a little bit less bad but it's still
not a fantastic number you want to be
running on if you want to unseat an
incumbent president compare it to
trump's favorability which is only 32
right now and pence is
even worse at 30. okay maybe it's not
a huge problem for joe biden so today
the rnc starts
we'll have to see what kind of a bump
donald trump gets out of it now
typically the way it goes
is that both candidates get bumps from
their respective conventions
but they're not permanent and some weeks
after the conventions numbers settle
back down
typically to where they were before the
conventions
started now what's interesting is that
biden's boost didn't come from doing
anything
spectacular or outrageous biden gave
a pretty milk toast coherent
normal speech we saw him relating
to people like a normal person to his
wife to his family
that's a big contrast to donald trump
and we talked about that a little bit
earlier
in the program aside from the people who
were expecting biden to implode
being disappointed we basically saw a
preview of what it would be like to have
a normal adult as president
we wouldn't have wacky things happening
every single day
we wouldn't have all these scandals and
some people in reaction to this are
emailing me and they're saying david
this is such a low bar this is not
enough
this is nothing to praise biden about i
see it as
yeah it's it's feels better
to have an adult in charge who's not a
laughing stock
the bar being low is not an attack on
biden
it's a reminder of how low donald trump
has set the bar
and it's even scarier that 60 million or
more people
are likely to vote for keeping the bar
that low by voting to re-elect donald
trump in november so when people say
biden only seemed okay because the bar
is so low
that's not an attack on biden that's an
attack on the guy who set the bar
so low and that's donald trump now what
does seem
less ideal is that according to this
same poll
only about 30 of americans even watched
any of the dnc
that's not great from from the
standpoint of enthusiasm
when you have a coronavirus pandemic
more people are staying home
the fact that fewer people watch this
than typically do is not great
however you can interpret that any
number of ways you could say the reason
fewer people watch the dnc
is they don't need to watch it to know
that they need to vote to remove donald
trump and vote for joe biden in november
it's one speculative interpretation
the point is the lower viewership
doesn't necessarily tell us
anything my expectation is that the
ratings for the rnc which starts tonight
are going to be much better
but they're going to be better not
because there's so many more republicans
enthusiastically waiting to vote for
donald trump compared to joe biden
there are going to be a lot of people
hate watching the rnc
or watching it the way we look at a car
crash when we drive by
i wouldn't necessarily read too much
into it i expect my
live streams of the rnc and again my
audience is
way more left than it is right i expect
my live streams to do better
for the rnc than the dnc but it's not
because my audience is planning to vote
for trump
it's because my audience wants to see
the train wreck that is going to be you
know the couple from st
louis who pointed guns at protesters
speaking at a convention the question
ultimately is
once the rnc is all said and done what
does it do for trump
imagine a republican convention that
damages trump that'd be terrible more
likely
trump will get two to three points out
of it in the short run
that may be enough for him to get
reelected
it may not it's just very difficult for
me to imagine
being on tv four days in a row in prime
time
and trump helping himself because he
seems to mess up at every opportunity
but
conventions aside the refrain has to be
the constant reminder has to be trump
can steal this election
post office shenanigans combined with
foreign meddling
combined with other voter suppression
combined with taking credit for anything
coronavirus related that happens between
now and november i know
we look at maps and we say looks so easy
for biden he's just got to take a couple
of these states trump won and he's got
270.
you only need to suppress the modest
amount of votes in key states to flip
the results
and because there's such a huge urban
rural divide in this country
if you're a republican you know
you can hugely help your candidate by
just doing shenanigans in urban areas
you know that when you do that you were
disproportionately going to hit people
likely planning to vote for joe biden
and not donald trump
they know this okay trust me they know
it last thing
the convention boosts being temporary
is fine but that still means
trump could be within two or three
points in the popular vote
and he won the electoral college in 2016
while being down more than two points in
the popular vote to hillary clinton
so what we can hope is different this
time around is that with early voting
the temporary boost may bleed over into
voting and if joe biden got five and
trump only gets two or three
maybe early voting will be skewed to
biden and that will take away the power
that some october surprise would have
we're thinking out loud
all we can do is vote i hope you will i
know i plan to
uh continue following us on instagram
for more on this story we're on
instagram at david pakman show